after consulting with his national
security council in the white house
situation room and a virtual meeting
with g7 leaders u.s president joe biden
made good on his promise to inflict
massive costs on russian president
vladimir putin for invading ukraine
putin is the aggressor
putin chose this war
and now he and his country will bear the
consequences
the new sanctions target major russian
banks and russian elites and in
coordination with allies representing
more than half the global economy are
designed to cut off russia from the
world's financial system russian assets
in the u.s are also now frozen
we will limit russia's ability to do
business in dollars euros pounds and yen
export controls to curtail russian
high-tech imports are also being imposed
to [ __ ] russia's military and
high-tech capabilities the moves are
backed by top congressional democrats
like senate leader chuck schumer who
condemned russia's invasion and pledged
support for ukraine ukrainians are tough
and resilient i know they will not give
up their country they will fight
fiercely for it but senate republican
leader mitch mcconnell is blaming biden
for the crisis
i think the precipitous withdrawal from
afghanistan in august was a signal
to putin and maybe to chinese president
xi as well
that america was in retreat
across america demonstrators protested
putin's invasion after a generation of
fighting in iraq and afghanistan most
americans are war weary in a recent poll
just 26 percent of americans support the
u.s playing a major role in the russian
ukraine conflict
biden has promised u.s troops won't be
sent to ukraine but if the conflict
spreads to a nato country u.s soldiers
already staged in europe would be
obliged to fight on thursday biden
reaffirmed that commitment to collective
nato defense
the united states will defend every inch
of nato territory with the full force of
american power president biden has
announced a nato summit will be convened
on friday the purpose to affirm support
for ukraine and map out the next steps
necessary to strengthen the nato
alliance kimberly hellcat al jazeera the
white house